[Music]
in this room who's uh who's everybody's
uh
favorite governor gavin newsom and gavin
newsom
all right that is a question that has
never been asked to me ever
before and i had no idea what to do
who's your favorite mayor then
jeff gordon wasn't schwarzenegger or our
governor
i know isn't this [ __ ] stated joke
and it's crazy to go
i want schwarzenegger yeah i want
schwarzenegger yeah i don't
know anyone that's a terminator with
gavin
well they didn't like him at all they
were saying that he was um
who was the leader before him was it
jeff uh no jerry brown
jerry brown's puppet oh really that's
what they were saying
he was just operating under the same
administration that was that was
the san francisco mayor i think isn't he
also like the nephew of some
like someone else too uh newsom
kevin newsom oh he's related to nancy
pelosi yeah pelosi
yeah got an n yeah like you know
they're all kind of connected so you'll
cut your ketchup you'll catch up yeah so
the reason why
like the lannisters and the banisters
and their i like the lannisters
yeah right yeah a lot of people are
upset with gavin newsom just because
a lot of people i think on both sides of
the political spectrum
don't really like what he's been doing i
wonder if you can win
as a politician like ever right everyone
just hates
you're always wrong like i don't know
half of everybody unless you die
i think you win by looking at your bank
account like abraham lincoln
so they're like we all love him right i
don't even remember when that happened
and then jfk we love him
but you have to get killed oh yeah you
mean like
i think politicians win when they go oh
[ __ ] i don't care if people love me or
hate me look at me i'm getting so rich
well not really because look at trump is
he in richer i don't think he even cares
i'm i'm assuming
i don't know if he cares about it they
get power through real estate [ __ ] who
knows
because like he gets the most [ __ ]
flack and he's like still doing his [ __ ]
not changing it might be a little bit i
mean even
obama had his own um a lot of haters
like people were like obama's a
terrorist
like he was never american to begin with
and then they even said like michelle
obama's like
like uh uh like a man and and
that's [ __ ] below the belt it's crazy
[ __ ] dude
like [ __ ] dude they were calling her a
monkey and [ __ ] like yeah yeah
they're drawing her as a gorilla they
even had them they had um
they made these puppet or mannequins
that looked like obama and hung him from
trees and [ __ ] it was [ __ ] wild it's
so crazy
yeah so like every president i think
there's like
nobody really loves them everyone hates
there's always someone that
isn't going to benefit from their
administration for sure and then there's
still people that go i want to be
president
i knowing all of this because you get
the power who you don't give a [ __ ] it's
power for sure
when you're that when you're in the
elite circles dude you don't give a [ __ ]
by the people don't we know that
haven't we seen evidence of that that's
true yeah so i bring up gavin newsom
uh because yeah yeah i don't think he's
been doing that greater job
with california hence why so many people
are leaving california
but maybe he's trying he's trying yeah
give him credit right
he's trying he is trying to do something
that i think is pretty cool
he is set to pass a bill that's going to
make
ethnic studies a graduation requirement
for high school students in the state
that's pretty cool i mean that's cool
and all but can we [ __ ] just
open up our businesses so that we can at
least live here true so that
kids can attend the [ __ ] pre-covered
the news would have been like that's
[ __ ] awesome
hey finally progress we got fires bro we
got a lot of small businesses that need
help can we just
can we take care of the faces
y'all are taxing people up the ass we
all want to leave
there's protesting there's yeah it's
like fix those problems both of my legs
are broken and he's like i got you
contacts
yeah i don't need [ __ ] contacts right
now unless your legs are broken he's
like i fix the stairs in your house
it's like all right that's kuna we're
gonna have like maybe
asian american studies as something that
all schools learn about
that's cool but [ __ ] it's just too
reactionary the state is [ __ ] burning
down bro what the [ __ ] there's bigger
things at hand right now that need to be
tended to
get ahead of it but yeah what are the
problems
but you know what let's take five
seconds and clap for this
he's trying finally some positive news
positive well fun fact though i found
out
in order to get ethnic studies even into
our school system
people had to demonstrate and fight for
it and
people were against this can you believe
that it all started off at uh
uc berkeley and the different cultural
clubs
were like hey like you know there's been
a lot of contribution in america from
minorities and we should have a whole
program studying and celebrating that
and they they were
violently oppressed by the
administration to even having that as a
curriculum
and so we came a long way from
them having to [ __ ] make
demonstrations in school
and then being uh hosed down by police
and what year was this
like in the 60s this was in the 60s
during the civil rights movement and
there's footage
right now in some high schools that's
tragically attacked by
the local community for wanting to study
a subject that's [ __ ] crazy people
are getting
jumped and [ __ ] up so that is a big i
think that is that is an awesome win
but hearing that as it just feels like
it just man like we have way bigger [ __ ]
right now to [ __ ] deal
absolutely absolutely uh but the
petition
that we're talking about here it states
our education system owes it to us to
equip us with the tools to adequately
navigate these systems yet our history
courses
largely focus on the highlights of
european and american history
disregarding the negative impacts of the
european experience
and misinforming us on how the us
government harmed and discriminated
against marginalized groups
i think it's a balance man because so
here's the thing like um the states are
in
charge of the uh kind of like grade
school education and like what's in the
curriculum right
and regionally like every we have
regional pride in america right so if
you grew up in texas you're going to
learn about the alamo and like
a lot about texas history if you're in
california you're going to learn about
the mission system you're going to learn
about like
you know spanish like like presence here
and then the natives
and then the same with the east coasters
they have a lot of pride in just
being um like the first founders out of
america right so it's hella disjointed
and so i think what ends up happening
though is we don't all have the same
history
so it's very common where outside of the
west coast i'm looked upon as a complete
[ __ ] foreigner
and not someone who's like american
whereas in the west coast
it's a little bit different where you do
learn about like
you know asians being involved in the
building of america
absolutely and like in alabama they
teach that dinosaurs don't exist so
right
they do they really don't know
they actually teach christianity stuff
in the school and then they don't teach
the evolution [ __ ] wow
dude i remember meeting someone in the
midwest where they thought that yoga was
a a sin and it's it's the devil's work
because it's spiritual or some [ __ ] or
not well
it got it's hot yoga i mean when girls
wear you
the devil loves the heat when girls wear
yoga pants though that's the devil's
work that's damn right
mix those two oh jesus
but yeah growing up in texas for me like
there was no talk about like
asian studies or anything like that and
like and you know what
i see it in the textbooks like there's a
paragraph for it
but the teacher would never they would
just skip right over it but oh that's
not important
stick within your page 45 to page 55.
here look uh there's this girl in tik
tok now that is getting um
she's getting lit up because she has a
japanese rising sun tattoo
oh and the koreans are i mean asian in
general
because they never really taught that in
school here you know like about the
breaking
you know yeah because it's more
eurocentric right so then
the swastika has this like big [ __ ]
negative like bias tour yeah the worst
negative it's like oh [ __ ] it's so bad
but then you know like millions of
people were killed under mao's like
thing and under the japanese imperial
army
fog tons of people were murdered too
like and we barely learned about that
stuff
and stalin too yeah lit up right now and
people like how [ __ ] do you not know
i didn't even know until like five years
ago was because they still use the flag
in japan too
because that wasn't the same as the nazi
flag like that was the
um navy's flag but it still has that
bad feeling that um they should get rid
of because of the
bad branding but we all know she was in
the tattoo shop and she's like oh pretty
son
i'll take that one well people are
saying well she served in the navy
for like a year or two also um and she's
filipina
so they're like she should have known
but i'm just like [ __ ] i'm done i like
that how people are like you should have
known
i am assuming you would know because of
this it's like bro
if people knew they probably wouldn't do
it unless they're like a full-on
yeah [ __ ] exactly i'm a japanese
imperialist
yeah as a filipino i am yeah
it's [ __ ] up though i think that's
what contributes to our disjointedness
and different idea of what is american
and then it kind of causes a lot of
infighting because we don't all
we don't all learn the same we don't
know the same things different countries
but the best place to attack this
problem like raises and all that stuff
is education yeah this is this is
positive bringing awareness from
from a a good mo a good point in
in a person's life in high school teach
that in school like you have to teach
the history of
every country so yeah so they're giving
it 10 years now
to develop this program before they
actually roll it out
there's a lot of information yeah i feel
like they need to start off with hey
it's okay
if everyone doesn't know everything yeah
and
as you live life you're gonna meet a lot
of people with different experiences and
you can't assume that they know
everything or experience
everything that you've experienced and
start off with that like the vietnamese
flag a lot of people
especially here don't like the flag with
the star because that's a communist flag
a lot of people in orange county still
fly the
the yellow with the red stripes the
adidas flag yeah the adidas flag
so it's like how are people supposed to
know this like i was taught that when i
was a kid like we don't we don't
we don't rock with the the star so now
even now like it's so indoctrinating me
that whenever i see that star flag i'm
like oh that's [ __ ] weird you know
like because i'm used to the yellow flag
yeah people just don't know and you
shouldn't [ __ ] on people for not knowing
these things because it's not our
country to know
yeah yeah like when people say konichiwa
to me i don't punch them in the face
exactly i just go oh this guy's trying
to
connect to texas and some old man was
like me how
thank you that's like my grocery store
they keep saying you out and there's
this one guy that keeps saying
how to me i'm like here hi out here or
here here yeah what do you say back yeah
but yeah and so one of the amendments
was to push the ethnic studies
to 2029 to 2030 year
as opposed to 2025 so they're trying to
extend it and trying to get this program
right
and another amendment that's happening
which i would say
is not a great look for this uh study is
that they're trying to adopt a locally
developed ethnic studies
so depending on where you live it's
still going to be disjointed it's
disjointed yeah exactly i feel like
everyone should learn the same thing
across the board no matter where you
live because
ultimately i feel like our world is
getting more and more uh integrated to
online life
you know and on and online it doesn't
matter where you live we all deal with
the same problems online
because people be like don't you know
the struggles of the new york chinatown
i'm like no i've never been there
so like we just we need like a common
theme that we all learned so we could be
more together absolutely but yeah so
hopefully this
uh this is a beginning of some good
change in our world
that's cool we'll see what happens yeah
it's funny when
my european friends know more about
america than my american friends
because they get educated on not only
their own country but the countries
around them
and our country but talk to people who
just became naturalized citizens
and they know the [ __ ] everything
that's true new immigrants know america
better than americans
yeah it's crazy
[Music]
so